very sad news that we woke up to this morning,
a really big loss to the activism community.
Congressman Elijah Cummings, a real civil
rights era hero, uh, has died at age 68.
Uh, his office reports the cause of death
as quote, complications concerning longstanding
health challenges.
It's known that he had a procedure recently.
The full details of everything that he was
battling have not been made public and comings
has been visible recently, um, as a house
Democrat because he's been involved in investigations
into Donald Trump.
He was involved in some key, a questioning
of Donald Trump's former personal attorney,
Michael Cohen before Cohen went to prison.
When he testified before a number of committees.
He was involved in a horrible controversy
with Donald Trump about rodent infested Baltimore.
But this is a man with a life of civil rights
activism under his belt.
He was a lawyer by education, but really an
activist at heart.
He had 12 honorary doctorate degrees when
he was 11 years old.
He helped to racially integrate a local swimming
pool while being attacked with bottles and
rocks in the Maryland house of delegates.
He was the youngest chairman of the legislative
black caucus.
Uh, also the first black American to be speaker
pro temp.
And more recently he's been on the forefront
of political battles around the shootings
of unarmed black men of Trump's impeachment,
the immigration crisis, child internment camps.
Really a loss.
And I'm sure we'll be looking at more and
more of his accomplishments, but just a bad
week of news all around, uh, out of the middle
East, out of the white house everywhere.
And really sad news to wake up to this morning.
Alijah Cummings dead at 68 and we will be
talking more about this upcoming.
Let's talk a little bit about the endorsement
game.